تحضير واسع في امريكا والمكسيك من مرض
قاتل مرتبط بعمليات التجميل هذا التحذير
اتى بعض الاعلان عن وفاه مواطنين امريكيين
نتيجه اصابتهم بالتهاب السحايا الفطري عقب
اجرائه عمليات جراحيه تتضمن التخدير داخل
عياده للتجميل في مدينه ماداموس شمال
المكسيك وعلى اثر ذلك السلطات المكسيكيه
قررت اغلاق هذه العياده وعياده اخرى
لتجميل في المدينه ذاتها اللافت في الامر
ان حوالي 400 شخص يخضعون للمتابعه في
امريكا والمكسيك باجرائهم فيما تمارس
عمليات تجميليه مثل شفط الدهون التي تتطلب
حقا تخدير في المنطقه المحيطه بالعمود
الفقري التحقيقات الاوليه تشير الى ان
شبهات ظهور التهاب السحايا تحم حول وجود
تلوث في الادويه المستخدمه اثناء التخدير
في المقابل يرى خبراء ان المرض ليس معديا
لكن قد يصبح مهدده للحياه بمجرد ان تبدا
الاعراض دون معالجتها وهي الصداع والحمى
والقيء والام الرقبه وعدم وضوح الرؤيه